Good morning Hank, it is Friday December 17th
2010. Time for the Project For Awesome! Is
that too much? Felt like a lot! Think I actually
hurt my shoulder.
Today is the day that YouTube is not about
kittens who are inspired by kittens but about
charity. You can participate in the Project
For Awesome all day, and all day tomorrow
by going to youtube.com/p4a or projectforawesome.com.
All day long, a huge army of commenters, including
Hank and me, will be running around going
to every Project For Awesome video we can
find and commenting on it like crazy and rating
and favoriting. And this year, there is added
incentive. Nerdfighters, you may know how
much I hate pennies. Well this year, Hank
and I will be donating one penny for every
Project For Awesome comment up to one million
comments. This year our pennies will go to
benefit 'Save The Children' and 'Partners
In Health', two charities that Nerdfighteria
has worked with extensively before, which
I am going to tell you about in a second.
But first I wanna tell you a story.
So Hank, a few years ago, just after the invasion
of Iraq, I was watching the news with my friend
Hassan, and they were showing this very nice
house thst had been bombed, and there was
a huge hole in the wall that had been covered
over with plywood. And on that plywood there
was all this Arabic graffiti in black spray
paint. And the news guy was talking about
the anger on the Arab street and everything
and then Hassan starts laughing and I say
"What's so funny?" and he said "The graffiti"
and I said "What's funny about it?" He said
"It says 'Happy Birthday Sir despite the circumstances'".
Hank, the news man and I had fallen into the
same trap. We both assumed it was political,
angry, violent graffiti not "Happy Birthday
Sir, despite the circumstances" graffiti and
ever since I've been thinking about why we
fell into that trap.
As humans we have a bad habit of imagining
people who live far away from us or are in
different circumstances from us, as fundamentally
'Other'. But in Nerdfighteria we've already
learned that people who live in very different
circumstances from us are not fundamentally
'Other'. We know it because we've seen what
happens when we work with 'Save The Children'
and Shaun's 'Uncultured Project' to build
a Pond Sand Filter in Bangladesh that after
two years is still providing clean water to
all these people. And we know it because with
the help of the 'Harry Potter Alliance' and
'Partners In Health', we were able to fly
the SS DFTBA, full of lifesaving supplies
to Haiti. We've already seen what happens
when you stop seeing people in poverty as
'Other' and start seeing them as part of 'Us'.
You know 'Us', people who do this to remind
themselves to be awesome. 'Us', people who
even in the wake of terrible tragedy find
a way to happy dance. We want to keep that
awesome going not only because it helps people
who live in poverty but also because it helps
us. It reminds us that when we look at graffiti
that we don't understand, it very may well
say "Happy Birthday Sir, despite the circumstances".
So every Project For Awesome comment, up to
a million comments is worth one penny to 'Partners
in Health' or 'Save The Children'. And if
you go to projectforawesome.com right now,
you'll find lots of amazing ways to donate
to great organizations. We've got raffle prizes
from Meekakitty and WheezyWaiter and Nerimon
and Ryan Higa and tons of other YouTubers
and lots of awesome nerdfighter raffles including
the chance to win my nerd glasses and the
last remaining BobbleJohn. Also, everyone
who enters my zombie apocalypse novella raffle
will be emailed the story, and one lucky winner
will receive the actual printed version of
the story, extensively annotated by me and
signed for the winner. But in my opinion,
the best raffle is the one where if you win,
your name will be the name of Hank's new album.
Like if the winner of the raffle's name is
Jeff, Hank's new album will be called 'Jeff'.
I'm gonna enter that one like 400 times.
So please go over to projectforawesome.com
to donate and join us all day today and tomorrow
at youtube.com/p4a to comment and rate and
favorite as many awesome P4A videos as possible.
Commenting army, I will see you at youtube.com/p4a
all day and night, where Hank and I will be
constantly uploading videos Old Spice Guy-style,
and may the 4th Project For Awesome be the
best one yet. Nerdfighters, thank you so much
for all your P4A videos, thank you for inspiring
us. Hank, DFTBA.
By the way, if you haven't subscribed to youtube.com/p4a,
you're not gonna have any fun today! I made
a rhyme! I am a rapper!
(To the John bobblehead)
You're my friend. Is it gonna be weird if
we kiss? You're so beautiful though! I want
it! It's wrong.